Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Ja.
Funst. Hallo Leute.
Kann man nicht bei YouTube deabonnieren?
Naja, wenn du verpassen willst,
ob es wieder was gibt dann kannst du dich die abonnieren ich kann ja aber
nicht sagen ich kann dir weder versprechen dass in nächster zeit was
kommt noch was alles rest musst du wissen ich würde mich natürlich nicht
abonnieren
gibt es jetzt auch battlefield 6 gameplay oder wieder nur heckermann
sachen wie soll es battlefield 6 gameplay geben das spiel ist gar nicht
ab aber diesen sonntag gab es aufwachen stream neues mikrofon nie aber es hört
sich irgendwie komisch an
wartet mal muss mir das selbst mal anhören gerade bla bla bla bla bla test
test test test bla bla bla bla bla hört sich an wie immer aber ich finde
auch dass ich es ein bisschen anders anhören.
Warte mal. Ich mach das mal kurz raus und wieder rein.
So.
Hä? Ist jetzt anders?
Es hört sich ein bisschen...
Ich gebe euch recht, weil ich hab's ja...
Ne, ne, ne. Übersteuern
tut eigentlich grad nix. Oder?
Nö. Also...
Ganz... Moment, ich muss mal kurz...
Es ist ja Windows. Dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
windows heißt im endeffekt jedes mal sind die audio settings ein bisschen anders wir gucken
mal kurz wartet mal open volume mixer ne warte mal wo input wo stellt man das noch mal ein sound
settings mikrofon ist eigentlich wie immer also es müsste vielleicht vielleicht höre ich mich
auch ein bisschen anders an.
Weil ich hab heute den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit
schon gemietet. Das kann sein.
Sonst, wenn ich on komme, hab ich nicht
den ganzen Tag geschwätzt vorher.
Also das könnte es vielleicht sein.
Sascha, danke für den Sub.
Fuck Subscription.
Du klingst ganz leicht.
Ja gut.
Das liegt daran,
weil ich den ganzen Tag gemietet
hab.
Teamrunde, Gruppenrunde,
Projekt Daily,
irgendwelche Hersteller-Calls,
Service-Dinger.
Das hört nicht auf.
Heute war der ganze Tag gemietet.
Ne, gesprintet haben wir diese Woche noch gar nicht.
Gesprintet werden wir nächste Woche wieder.
Kein Sprint.
Ja, ja, das Problem, warum ich kein Battlefield 6 gespielt habe, ist das, was heute im Streamtitel steht.
Man braucht für den Anti-Cheat von Battlefield 6...
Toasty, danke schon für den Sub. Exzellente Subscription hier.
Man braucht für den Anti-Cheat von Battlefield 6 braucht man Secure Boot und ich habe keinen Secure Boot.
und Mr2003
und das will ich
heute mal ausprobieren, ob ich Veracrypt mit Secure Boot
zum Laufen kriege, weil ich hab seit
über 10 Jahren
habe ich alle meine Rechner
also alle Windows Kisten
mit Veracrypt voll verschlüsselt
und
ich hab gelesen
dass Veracrypt
mit Secure Boot nicht
zusammen funktioniert
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht okay bevor ich das jetzt ausbauen wieder es gibt ich
halt die battlefield 6 beta und guck mir mal an ob ich das nicht irgendwie zum laufen kriege
ja ich verkaufe ich meine schitt coin
warum ich dich mit locker nehme mit locker ist bei mir unten durch
so ungefähr würde ich aussehen mit BitLocker
BitLocker ist bei mir unten durch
weil, das hatten wir in den letzten Stream schon
weil eines der ersten
News, die ich über BitLocker
gelesen habe, war
wenn man sein Passwort
vergessen hat, kann man es irgendwie
bei Microsoft wieder recoveren
und das widerspricht ja grundsätzlich
einer gescheiten Verschlüsselungslösung
gescheite Verschlüsselung heißt
Passwort weg, alles weg
muss ja so sein
sonst ist es ja per Design
unsecure
wenn es nicht so wäre
und
das ist das erste was ich damals über BitLocker gelesen hab
und seitdem
mag ich BitLocker nicht mehr
womit mich beschützen will
hauptsächlich dass ich meine Platten
wenn sie kaputt sind
wenn ich sage Platte
Ja, da meine ich sowohl HDDs als auch SSDs.
Der hauptsächliche Grund ist, dass selbst wenn die Platte mal kaputt ist, dass ich die in den Müll schmeißen kann und keiner mit den Daten drauf was anfangen kann.
Also muss ich mal überlegen, was man da alles drauf hat.
Irgendwelche medizinischen Dokumente, Passwörter, WLAN-Credentials, alles mögliche.
Und das willst du ja eigentlich nicht in den Müll schmeißen.
Lass die halt professionell vernichten.
Tja, kannst du ja machen lassen, aber ich wüsste nicht mal wo ich hin muss, um meine
Platten professionell vernichten zu lassen.
Und man kann das ganze Problem ja relativ easy umgehen, indem man sein System einfach
voll verschlüsselt.
Die beste Variante wäre natürlich Vollverschlüsselung plus professionell vernichten lassen.
Mit Bohrmaschine durch?
Da wäre ich mir bei SSDs nicht so sicher.
Du bist aus Hanau geflüchtet?
Ich wohne ja auch nicht direkt in Hanau.
Ich wohne so nebendran.
Hanau selbst ist ziemlich
Crap. Warum bist du
Express, Expressive?
Muss ich ja mal fragen. Warum bist du geflüchtet aus Hanau?
Also ich finde Hanau Innenstadt auch
ganz schlimm.
Du hast jeden Speicherschiff mit dem Hammer umgehauen.
Ja, seht ihr Leute?
Ihr seid alles Kandidaten für
einfach Vollverschlüsselung.
Und ihr müsst euch keine Gedanken mehr machen.
Ich mach das hauptsächlich aus, wie nennt man das so?
Ease of Use oder so?
Gründen?
Ich mache es nicht
für den Fall der Fälle,
dass hier das FBI sozusagen vor der Tür steht,
weil dann
hast du andere Probleme.
Weil man muss sich mal eine Sache, das muss ich jetzt
vielleicht mal gerade noch dazu
sagen. Es gibt ja Leute,
die
denken, dass
Festplattenvollverschlüsselung
Lamboy,
ja Lamboy ist ja quasi
mitten in Frankfurt, Lamboy ist schrecklich,
war es früher auch schon.
Genauso wie Freiheitsplatz und sowas.
Nee
Du kannst ja eventuell nicht mal auf die Festplatte zugreifen
Stell dir vor
Deine Festplatte
Ist kaputt
Und du schmeißt sie in den Müll
Willst du das
Jemand die Sache noch restauren kann
Also ich mein
Es sind ja Festplatten nicht jetzt automatisch unlesbar
Nur weil sie
Nicht mehr anspringen
Ja, die Chancen sind nicht hoch, aber ich finde es vom Ansatz her schon irgendwie unschön.
Das ist genau so, das ist übrigens genau das gleiche wie IoT-Geräte wegschmeißen.
Was ja eines der Hauptgründe war, warum ich mir mittlerweile Access Points angeschafft habe, die Passwörter pro Gerät vergeben können.
Weil dann kannst du das Gerät wegschmeißen, löscht das Passwort aus deinem Access Point und ist weg.
Weil ansonsten ist in jedem IoT-Gerät, was du in den Müll schmeißt, dein WLAN-Passwort drin.
Das finde ich auch vom Ansatz her unschön.
Die Chancen, dass das mal wirklich irgendjemand ausliest, sind wahrscheinlich vernachlässigbar gering.
Aber ich finde es vom Ansatz her schon kacke.
Ja, und das ist der Hauptgrund, warum ich alles voll verschlüsselt habe.
Aber ich wollte noch mal was dazu sagen.
Ähm, gibt ja Leute, die sind der Meinung, Festplattenverschlüsselung ist Hilfe gegen alles.
Also, naja, gegen alles ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
Was ich meine ist, Leute denken, dass Festplattenverschlüsselung quasi gegen alle, gegen jeglichen Zugriff sichert und sowas in der Richtung.
Das ist aber zu kurz gedacht.
Ja, also, gehen wir jetzt mal von aus.
Gehen wir jetzt mal von aus.
irgendjemand hat irgendjemand ist arbeitet bei bei irgendeiner journalist arbeitet bei
irgendeiner zeitung oder so ja oder reist beispielsweise mit seinem laptop was ist
so typisches land so keine ahnung so syrien in der ecke oder so ja da muss er voll zur
sache geht reist da irgendwie so nahen osten in den land ein und veröffentlicht dort irgendwie
vielleicht artikel oder recherchiert irgendwas was den machthabern dort nicht gefällt so jetzt
hat er sein notebook dabei und hat seine festplatten voll verschlüsselt könnte es genauso
gut beim anderes beispiel reist in die usa ein ist im prinzip ja auch kein unterschied du reist in
irgendein land ein wo du weißt dass die machthaber es nicht so nicht so genau nehmen ja mit kann es
schreiben und sagen was du willst so oder nach china oder sowas zum beispiel so und jetzt
überlegt euch mal was passieren wird wenn er den sein notebook gibt die werden das notebook
aufklappen die sagen rück alles raus was du hier an material hast sonst kommst du nicht weg
die nehmen das Notebook von ihm, machen das Notebook auf
und sehen dann Festplattenvollverschlüsselung
so, jetzt gibt es zwei Varianten
und ihr dürft mir jetzt gleich mal sagen, welche der Varianten ihr für realistisch erhaltet
es gibt zwei Varianten, um an das Notebook ranzukommen
entweder die eigene krasse Hackerman Taskforce
darauf ansetzen, mit zig 5090
klastern und versuchen die festplatte zu hacken oder dem typ so lange die fresse
einschlagen bis das passwort raus rückt was meint ihr wird in solchen ländern
wahrscheinlicher passieren
das zweite ja da gehe ich auch mal davon aus hoch warum ist denn die um ist denn
der Sound aus. Hier, Songs and Smiles.
Passt ja richtig gut gerade, ne?
Zu dem Thema.
So.
Und dementsprechend,
da hat die Festplatten-Vollverschlüsselung
halt überhaupt nichts gebracht. Also es ist
ein Unterschied zwischen, also wenn ich
sage, es ist ein Unterschied zwischen, irgendwas ist so
IT-mäßig, ähm,
Computer-Science-mäßig
sicher, versus
es ist auch in der Realität sicher, ja?
hacken oder irgendwie
drauf zugreifen mit einem ordentlichen Passwort,
wird das keiner können. Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
irgendwelche Geheimdienste mit krassen Ressourcen,
wenn das eine ordentliche Verschlüsselungslösung
und ein ordentliches Passwort ist. Aber
gegen das zweite Beispiel,
was ich genannt habe,
bringt das nichts.
Können wir über den NPM-Hack reden?
NPM Hack
ist wieder typisches
Keck JavaScript.
Wobei es ja nicht
wirklich streng genommen ein NPM
Hack ist, sondern
ein gefischter
Entwickler,
der JavaScript Packages auf
NPM veröffentlicht.
Nur mal für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt
haben, ich versuche das mal
kurz zusammenzufassen. Und Leute,
ihr müsst jetzt aufpassen, dass ich kein Mist erzähle,
weil ich habe das zwei Minuten schnell überflogen und dann mich nicht mehr mit befasst.
Also, es gab wohl einen Phishing-Angriff auf...
Dauernuss, danke schön für den Sub.
Es gab wohl einen Phishing-Angriff auf einen Entwickler von weit verbreiteten NPM-Packages.
Also hier, NPM.
NPM.
Hier.
So, der Entwickler hat eine E-Mail bekommen von npmjs.help und in dieser E-Mail stand drin, bitte aktualisieren Sie Ihre Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
der hat auf den Link in der E-Mail geklickt
warum ihm das passiert ist
weiß man nicht, er hat eine Stellungnahme
geschrieben mit so nach dem Motto, war ein harter Arbeitstag
hat nicht richtig nachgedacht, kann ich
verstehen, manche Phishing Sachen sind
auch so gut mittlerweile gemacht, dass es, du bist
wirklich kurz davor drauf zu klicken
ähm, und in der E-Mail
Schale drinnen klicken sie um ihre 2 Faktor Authentifizierung
zu bestätigen oder so diese
typischen Phishing Geschichten, hat er gemacht
und dann hatten die Hackermans
Zugang auf seinen NPM Account
und konnte neue JavaScript-Packages veröffentlichen.
Da waren einige weit verbreitete Pakete dabei, zum Beispiel war es Chalk, glaube ich, heißt das.
Das ist so ein Paket, um grafisch, nee, nee, nicht grafisch, bunte Kommandozeilen-Ausgabe zu machen.
Dann Debug und ich glaube Error.js oder Error.es oder irgendwie sowas ist auch noch dabei gewesen.
So und da kommen wir jetzt zum Thema KekW JavaScript. Das Ding ist halt, dass da Gott und die Welt Dependencies hat. Also das ist ja normal, dass bei JavaScript, wenn du ein Package installierst, so ein ganz unscheinbares Package, hast du das halbe Internet runtergeladen.
Da gibt es ja dieses typische NPM, kennt ihr bestimmt, Black Hole Meme.
Ja, was ist noch massereicher als ein schwarzes Loch?
Was ist noch massereicher als ein schwarzes Loch? Da gibt es nur noch Node Modules.
und dementsprechend haben sich halt ganz viele Leute
diese Packages
als Dependency
gezogen, ohne es zu wissen
Glück über Unglück wieder
das wurde alles relativ schnell erkannt
und auch wieder gefixt
ich weiß nicht, wie es gefixt wurde, ob
die im Repo eine neue Version
published haben oder ob die alte zurück
gedreht wurde, keine Ahnung
weiß ich nicht aber das wurde relativ schnell gefixt also die chancen sind
gering aber sie sind auf jeden fall da dass jeder der viel mit npm und
javascript entwicklung gemacht hat die letzte woche sollte mal gucken ob er da
nicht von betroffen ist guck dir mal disk krypto das kommt mir
irgendwie bekannt vor ist das nicht dieses ding wo es auch eine android app
und eine ios app für gibt
Ne, das ist wieder was anderes, ne?
Aber warum soll ich mir das ankommen?
Vera Crypt ist beste.
Das sieht sogar ein bisschen aus wie das alte True Crypt.
Sieht sogar ein bisschen so aus.
Und warum ist das besser als Vera Crypt?
Ich denke nicht, dass das besser ist.
Guck mal.
Ja, GPT unterstützen, aber unterstützen sie auch Secure Boot?
GPT unterstützt VeraCrypt mittlerweile auch.
Genau, das ist das, was ich gemeint habe.
Das ist nicht wirklich ein NPM-Hack.
Aber eins muss man sagen, bei NPM ist es schon oft vorgekommen.
Noch schlimmer früher bei NPM war,
dass NPM ungefragt irgendwelche Post-Install-Skripts ausgeführt hat, die mit User-Rechten liefen.
Das ist ja mittlerweile, glaube ich, nicht mehr so.
Glaube ich.
Gelesen zu haben.
Kannst damit die komplette Platte verstehen, das kann ich mit Veracrypt auch.
Hast du gesehen, dass Arte auf YouTube-Geräte...
Ach.
Da ist ja ein guter Gesellschaft.
Ich weiß noch, wo der Channel vom mCore auf einmal Crypto Bros Content hatte.
Ne, Fault Verschlüsselung ist nicht überall Default.
Die meisten Desktop-Systeme dürften ohne jegliche Verschlüsselung laufen.
Echt? Warum? Was gab es nicht? Also, wenn du was wissen willst, kannst du fragen.
Oder ist es die typische Sache wie in der Schule, wo der Lehrer gefragt hat, was habt ihr nicht verstanden?
Und die Antwort war eher alles.
Ja, noch machen wir gerade gar nichts.
Noch habe ich eigentlich nur was zu der NPM-Geschichte der letzten Woche erzählt, dass Malware-Packages veröffentlicht wurden.
Ne.
Also meins macht Sinn.
Wir werden gleich sehen, ob es das macht.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, wir müssen noch Windows 11 runterladen.
Brauchen wir.
Windows 11 herunterladen.
Muss das wirklich die deutsche Version sein?
Kann man da nicht irgendwas anderes?
Multi-Edition-ISO.
Kann man das auch in Englisch installieren?
Dies kann einige Minuten dauern.
Was machen die denn da wieder?
Auf jeder x-beliebigen kleinen Crap-Seite
klicke ich auf einen Download-Link
und
das lädt dann einfach.
Aber Microsoft nicht.
Das wird erstmal fünf mal in Azure im Kreis geschickt wahrscheinlich.
Über irgendwelche Cloud Functions wird dann die Webseite gerendert.
FFM Pack Video zu HTML falls es sowas gibt.
So okay jetzt lädt er runter.
Was? Arm64?
Ne, oder?
Stand da nicht.
Äh, welchen Browser war ich denn gerade?
Hier? Ah, ChatG.
Ach, ne.
Das sind xxxx.
Hier gibt es für Armgeräte.
Okay.
Ne, kenne ich nicht
Aber sieht aus, als könnte man da irgendwelche Windows-Install-Skripts
Die haben letztens ihre Surfaces mit einem Bild von einem iPad beworben
Ne, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt
Ich hatte mal einen Surface
Auf der alten Arbeit war das die
Einer der ersten Surface-Generationen
War das Standard-Notebook, was man gekriegt hat
Aber das hatte ich nicht lang
Da lief aber Ubuntu drauf
konnte damals ubuntu installieren jubantu
er weiß ich habe ich nicht benutzt ich habe auf der arbeit meiner eigenen tastatur die habe ich
auch immer noch ich habe seit ja ich habe seit ein paar jahren für auf der arbeit habe ich das
ding hier ja nur die nur mit hier die da nicht nicht die ducky one skyline ich habe die normale
Lucky One Skyline, aber
so ungefähr sieht die aus.
Also was arbeitest du?
Also in meinem Arbeitsvertrag steht,
dass ich Senior Linux Engineer bin.
Klingt geil, oder?
Ja, kann ich empfehlen.
Das Ding ist echt gut.
Ist eine mechanische Tastatur, macht ziemlich klickety-klick.
Aber ich habe unter die Enter-Taste und noch ein paar anderen habe ich so kleine Silikonringe drunter gemacht,
dass wenn ich da drauf pfeffer, so bam, dass es nicht alle Leute im Büro abfuckt.
Aber ich bin eher Senior Meeting Engineer.
Heute habe ich auch den ganzen Tag gemietet.
Ich glaube, ich habe heute eine sinnvolle Sache gemacht, den ganzen Tag.
Und das war, na gut, man könnte sich jetzt streiten, ob das Gemiete nicht auch sinnvoll war, aber außerhalb von Gemiete habe ich eine Sache gemacht und zwar ich habe einen Backup restored und das ist im Endeffekt eigentlich nur ein Restore-Skript starten und dann zugucken.
Also man muss nicht wirklich zugucken
Also ich hab ein Backup-Restore gemacht
Hier so nach dem Motto
Restore.sh
Blablablub
Und hab Enter gedrückt
Das war's, was ich heute sinnvolles
Außer Gemiete gemacht hab
Ich find auch
Ich find auch, ja
Das ist aber nicht das
Wie heißt das? 10x Engineer Mindset?
ja ja wir haben auf der arbeit wir haben auf der arbeit einen eigenen chat gpt fork das ist
bei das ist das ist falsch ist kein chat gpt fork wir betreiben kein eigenes chat gpt es gibt von
microsoft quasi customizes chat gpt s service das haben wir und bei uns gibt es die möglichkeit das
habe ich aber nie ausprobiert, das will ich aber mal ausprobieren,
einen eigenen trainierten,
ne, muss ich anders sagen,
einen eigenen Chatbot zu erstellen,
das ist bestimmt auch in den Azure Service
oder so, vermutlich, man kann einen eigenen
Chatbot erstellen, den man dann
füttert mit eigenen Inhalten, da könnte
man zum Beispiel seine,
wenn man ein Wiki hat, könnte man da beispielsweise
sein Wiki reinschmeißen und dem Chatbot
dann Fragen stellen über die eigenen
Systeme und sowas.
Habe ich auch nicht ausprobiert, habe ich aber mal vor.
echte meetings oder teams team meetings in real life mache ich gern da ist beides ich war in
frankfurt vor ort ich habe sowohl in echt gemietet als auch virtuell gemietet also
wenn ich wenn ich den eigenen chat bot machen würde dann würde der nur in twitch immer ausreden
Und wenn dann einer Windows-Fragen macht, macht er dann...
Hast du Tipps, wie man der Informatik näher kommt?
Also das Verstehen von...
Ja, sich Sachen von anderen Leuten angucken, was die...
Also wenn du jetzt Programmiersprachen meinst, ja.
Sich Code von anderen Leuten angucken.
aber es kommt immer ein bisschen davon an kommt ein bisschen darauf an was du
für vorkenntnisse hast also das ist so dass die frage ist so allgemein breit
gestellt da kann ich fast nichts richtig zu sagen
das hatte ich heute auch wir hatten ein team wir hatten ein teams meeting und
paar leute von denen in meinem büro waren auch in dem gleichen teams meeting
habe ich nicht gesehen habe ich nicht gesehen
im letzten sprint habe ich auch nicht viel gepackt ich habe heute backup
restore gemacht kann ich sagen hier waren das task abgeschlossen hat fünf
minuten gedauert wobei das geile ist ja chat das geile ist ja das backup hat
dann sogar noch die test umgebung kaputt gemacht
Die geht jetzt nicht nach dem Backup-Restore.
Leute, da muss ich sagen, da war ich tatsächlich ein wenig pfeifett heute Morgen.
Ich habe auf unserem Daily gefragt, Leute, spricht von irgendjemand aus irgendeiner Sicht dagegen,
dass ich jetzt mal in unserer Testumgebung den Backup-Restore teste, ob der noch funktioniert.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert.
Wir haben das Restore-Skript wieder gefixt.
Aber ausprobiert haben wir es noch nicht.
Und bevor wir das in Produktion machen, will ich es mal in Test ausprobieren.
Haben sie gesagt, passt schon, spricht nichts dagegen.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay Max, da geht bestimmt irgendwas schief.
Und deswegen habe ich gleich gefragt, sagt mal, braucht jemand von euch heute oder in den nächsten Tagen unbedingt die Testumgebung?
Nicht, dass das jetzt kaputt geht und danach heißt, ihr könnt nichts mehr machen oder so.
Dann haben alle gesagt, nee, nee, passt schon.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, machst du Backup-Restore.
Und was ist passiert?
Backup-Restore gelaufen.
Umgebung kaputt.
Und wisst ihr, warum die Umgebung kaputt ist?
So ein richtig dummer Clouds- und dann Fire-Armler.
Ich habe es heute nicht gefixt.
Ich habe es im Chat geschrieben, dass die Umgebung kaputt ist.
Wie schon geahnt, dass die Umgebung kaputt ist.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, wie wir das genau fixen.
Ich kann euch übrigens sagen, woran es liegt, dass die Umgebung kaputt ist.
Das habe ich tatsächlich neben dem Gemiete rausgefunden.
Da habe ich ein bisschen geguckt.
Die Umgebung ist kaputt, weil folgendes.
Also, wir haben einen Kubernetes-Cluster.
Der hat Nodes in Standort A und B.
Es gibt aber in dieser Region drei Standorte, A, B, C und das Restore-Skript hat das Backup restored in C.
und jetzt versuch dort irgendeinen
Pod in Kubernetes hochzufahren
in dem drinnen steht, mounte dir mal
ein Volume von
Location C
aber der kann nicht, weil er
auf einem Node in Location B läuft
und ich weiß jetzt noch nicht genau, wie wir
das fixen, ehrlich gesagt
weil letztendlich
muss das Backup irgendwo in A oder B rauskommen
noch unsicher, warum es überhaupt in C rausgekommen ist.
Warum hast du das nicht am Freitagnachmittag gemacht?
Freitagnachmittag passiert noch was viel Besseres.
Freitagnachmittag geht vielleicht, oder Montagfrüh geht vielleicht die Produktion kaputt.
Von einem Service, der nicht so extrem wichtig ist.
Aber, und zwar, wir haben, ich weiß nicht, ist bei irgendjemand auf der Arbeit
Zertifikatsmanagement, nicht
Painschamp.
Läuft das irgendwo gut?
So Zertifikate rechtzeitig austauschen
und solche Geschichten. Gibt es irgendwo, wo das gut läuft?
Jetzt kommt mir nicht mit,
man kann das theoretisch automatisieren
und bla bla bla, dass man das theoretisch machen kann,
weiß ich auch.
Bei uns klappt das nicht komplett automatisch.
Zum Teil schon, aber
vieles nicht.
Also, das Ding ist, wir haben seit knapp 60 Tagen, haben wir eine Fehlermeldung bei uns im Monitoring, Zertifikat läuft ab.
Wobei es streng genommen nicht wirklich ein Zertifikat ist, was abläuft, sondern die alte CA von Let's Encrypt, vielleicht hat jemand von euch das gleiche Problem,
die haben ihre ca geschichten umgestellt und am 15 15 10 läuft die alte ca ab von
letzten crypt x2 ca läuft ab von letzten crypt und irgendjemand wollte von uns
anfang des jahres dass wir diese ca dass wir dieser ca trusten quasi dass man das
in so ein Java Trustsort packt.
Haben wir gemacht.
So, und jetzt gibt es seit knapp 60 Tagen
gibt es schon bei uns im Monitoring eine Meldung.
Ey, Leute, am 15.
morgens läuft das ab.
Ich habe
das schon über 5 Mal den Leuten
geschrieben, die dafür zuständig sind.
Wahrscheinlich
nicht. Es muss eine
spezielle alte X2
CA sein. Da muss man
bei Let's Encrypt gucken,
mal danach suchen. Ich hab den
schon über 5 mal, 5 mal reicht nicht, wahrscheinlich
8, 9 mal geschrieben. Leute,
am 15. dann und dann
läuft es ab. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das noch benutzt wird.
Letztendlich sagt
mir doch mal, was wir jetzt machen
oder wenn es nicht mehr gebraucht wird, sagt mir das nicht mehr
gebraucht wird. Die haben sogar teilweise drauf
geantwortet, nix, nix. Und heute
Morgen hab ich nochmal geschrieben, hab gesagt, Leute,
wir haben jetzt genau noch
2 Tage Zeit, bis wir
vielleicht einen Produktionsausfall haben
am Montag. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wofür das benutzt wird letztendlich, dass das
da getrusted wird.
Und da hat sich dann doch einer dazu
mal die Ehre gegeben
und hat gesagt, er guckt nach,
ob das noch benutzt wird. Er glaubt nicht,
dass es noch benutzt wird. Ich hoffe, er sagt
mir Bescheid. Zurücklehnen und
Popcorn essen, das habe ich mir auch
gedacht, aber mein Chef hat gesagt,
ich soll
denen nochmal explizit morgen sagen, das läuft
ab und sie sollen es doch
in Integration, in der Integrationsumgebung
beziehungsweise sagen wir mal in der Testumgebung
testen. Das rausnehmen, das Zertifikat und
gucken, ob da noch alles funktioniert.
Mein Chef will sich nicht zurücklehnen und Popcorn
essen. Ich hätte das auch gemacht.
Ähm.
Stimmt, hast schon
recht. Ich hätte das auch gemacht.
Ich hätte mir das bestätigen lassen
von denen, dass es egal ist
und dann mit dem Hinweis, wir haben Produktionsprobleme
Konfessionsprobleme und wenn die dann nicht darauf reagiert hätte ich mir gedacht reagiere ich nicht drauf aber letztendlich war ehrlich gesagt so aus
Wie sagt mein chef immer so aus service orientierter sicht ja oder aus kunden kunden orientierter sicht sagt er ja
Ist das wahrscheinlich nicht die beste variante und da würde ich ihm sogar recht geben wir lassen uns gegen die wand fahren
Ist wahrscheinlich für alle beteiligten nicht die beste variante
und daran sieht man mal wieder deswegen ist er der chef und ich ich weil ich
hätte so gemacht ich hätte gegen die wand fahren lassen
nachdem ich sie in acht mal gesagt haben wir mehrere wochen und dann hätte ich
gesagt ja ich hab's doch gesagt aber will ja ich lasse ich wieder
sidetracken ohne ende
Hast du Tipps für Vorbereitung auf die...
Oh, nee. Ja, doch.
Alte Abschlussprüfung machen.
Ja.
Das reicht.
Mach dir keine Gedanken.
Wenn du alte Abschlussprüfung gemacht hast
und dabei gut weggekommen bist.
Easy.
Oh, ich hab nix zu trinken hier.
Ich müsste mir gleich mal was holen.
Die wachen nicht auf, wenn was gegen die Wand fährt.
Du bist ein Self-Trott-Senior-Developer.
Nice.
Das ist schön, dass dir das geholfen hat.
Ich finde es ja nice, dass meine Videos auch
positiven Effekt bei manchen Leuten haben.
So.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was habe ich eigentlich für eine Vera?
Moment.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich euch das zeigen will.
Wartet mal kurz.
Oder versprecht ihr mir, dass ihr wegguckt?
Ich hab Veracrypt
1, 2, 5, 9.
Ich find dieses Emote so geil,
Alter, Leute.
Das brauch ich, Leute, das brauch ich
auch noch hier in meinem...
Wartet mal. Das muss ich hinzufügen.
Das ist einfach zu geil.
Bonk, bonk, ass.
Das ist einfach zu nice.
speichern unter das ist weg warum ist es in so einem track format das kann man
tool nicht kann man da nicht einfach jpg oder png oder jpg jpg mein tool kann
das nicht outdated tool ja das tool ist outdated as fuck das ist von wo ist es
überhaupt warum kann man sich hier nichts mehr anzeigen lassen
hier ist es das liegt unter das miem tool hier
das stimmt nicht da habe ich rüber kopiert da habe ich rüber kopiert die eigentliche
die eigentlichen falls 2018 und und selbst da bin ich mir sicher ob es daher kommt
Mach mal .gif
Du hast recht
Ich bin dämlich, warum jpg
Ich suche ja Animation
Da ist es doch, keck g
Hut ab, dass es heute noch läuft
Das ist noch altes .net Framework
Das funzt immer unter Windows
Das ist ganz gut hier.
Keck G.
Okay, Leute.
Achtung.
Test.
Keck G.
Sehr gut.
Das brauche ich.
Gut.
So.
Warum habe ich den Chat zugemacht?
Richtig hängen geblieben jetzt.
Öffentlicher Dienst, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das nervlich aushalten würde.
So, wie lange habe ich mich jetzt sidetracken lassen?
40 Minuten.
Ich glaube, das ist ein guter Schnitt für mich.
Würdest du sagen, dass 3.750 Euro als Gehalt nach der Ausbildung zum Physikgut ist?
13, 14, 12 Monatsgehälter?
Gucken wir mal.
Mal 12.
Das geht.
So richtig krass ist es nicht.
Aber das ist okay.
So zum Einstieg.
Wenn es denn halt auch Aussicht gibt, auf dass es mehr wird.
Ja, also mein allererstes Gehalt war 33.600 Euro nach der Ausbildung, aber das ist schon, naja, 20 Jahre ist es noch nicht her, aber es fehlen nicht mal viel dazu.
Und wenn man das, wir haben das mal umgerechnet mit Inflation und so, ja, 33.600 Euro.
Und wir haben das mal hochgerechnet, glaube ich, inflationsmäßig und ich bilde mir ein, wir sind so bei 45k irgendwie rausgekommen, was das heute bedeuten würde.
Kommt ja ziemlich genau hin. 33 schon gut, ich glaube, das ist doch unter Mindestlohn, oder? Mittlerweile.
Ich bin 33 heute zu wenig für den Job.
Meine Katze?
Keine von meinen Katzen lebt noch.
Sättge.
Und Chico, Chico, die unten rechts auch nicht mehr.
Wo ist die Original, wo ist Original-Cuts-FPS da?
So, aber jetzt haben wir Windows runtergeladen.
Jetzt können wir mal anfangen.
Neue VMA-Stellen.
Also, mein Ziel ist folgendes.
ich versuche jetzt vera kripp zu installieren auf einer frischen windows installation in der
version die ich habe und da gucke ich ob damit secure boot funktioniert wenn damit nicht secure
boot funktioniert dann update ich auf die allerneuste version wenn damit auch nicht
secure boot funktioniert da gucken wir mal ob es irgendwie eine möglichkeit gibt es mit secure
zum laufen zu bekommen also next next next windows aber auch sein wenn das elf
next meinetwegen secure keck b heißt das jetzt was
mir egal in crypto alles massive geiles passwort achtung kommt ihr nie drauf was
ich dafür ein passwort verwende top secret sich secure genug mein passwort
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
eilig secure secure boot nein eine cpu mit vier kurs ich habe mir alles genug
kurs und keiner 8 g gramm sollte reichen da hat wunderbar alles perfekt so genau
so will ich das haben single disc 64 gig müsste reichen geht auch schnell zu
verschlüsseln sagt customer ist hardware als ein
Einzige was wir brauchen ist den Printer weg und den USB Controller weg und der Rest passt.
Finish.
Was sind die 78 GB RAM?
Was?
Wo 78?
Anste hier?
Memory?
oder was du kannst ja vor allem mehr ram geben als du arbeitsspeicher hast dann
es war das das ist aber doof wieso vor allem der workstation warum nicht ist
doch eigentlich boxmarkt warum soll ich box moment mal vor allem workstation ist
desktop virtualisierung boxmark ist eine komplett eigene kiste die gelaufen haben
muss das ist doch zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar schuhe boxbox
könnte ich egal laufen lassen immer mein windows
überhaupt nicht funktionieren so
wirst du sich eigentlich so testen wäre club aktivieren dann secure boot
aktivieren das ist richtig da hast du recht du hast recht du hast recht ja du
hast recht das machen wir stellen dass wir stellen das mal so nach wir stellen
das mal so nach wie ich aktuell auf einem rechner habe hast recht ja ist
gut idee chat pfeift
Vmware ist nice, also für Desktop-Virtualisierung fällt mir eigentlich nichts besseres ein.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit gab es ja auch Diskussionen, ob Proxmox oder Vmware, aber
keine Chance im Business Enterprise Umfeld.
language to install englisch okay time and currency format da machen wir mal da machen
wir tatsächlich germany next next ich kriege mit allem kriege machen wir product
key pro accept so wisst ihr was wir machen können chat ich habe eine frage also wollen
wir jetzt der Windows-Installation zugucken und ich
labere euch einfach noch ein bisschen das Ohr ab.
Oder wollen wir nochmal in das Docker-File
von letztem Stream reingucken, weil
mir ist da was eingefallen, was wir noch ausprobieren
könnten. Wir hatten ja
so eine self-contained.net-Applikation
gebaut mit Web-Interface.
Mir ist nämlich noch was eingefallen, wie ich das
Docker-Bild besser machen
könnte.
Next.
Was geht mit meiner Mauszeige
ab da unten?
Yes, install.
Noch nicht mal.
Der Windows-Install ist hier irgendwie einheitlich.
Ja gut, das braucht jetzt kurz.
Dann gucken wir doch da nochmal kurz rein.
Während Windows installiert.
Weil so spannend ist das jetzt ja nicht.
Kein Bock?
Nee.
Das ist es nicht.
Ich habe das letzten Stream beantwortet.
Ich will das nicht jeden Stream erzählen, weil das jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein super beliebtes Thema ist.
Es hat aber weder was mit Twitch noch mit YouTube zu tun, dass es da wenig gibt, sondern es liegt an mir.
Ich habe gerade andere Probleme.
Ich glaube, das kann man so am besten sagen.
So, Dockerfile.
Also, was wir in unserem Dockerfile machen ist, wir bauen unser Frontend, wir bauen unser Backend,
bauen eine .NET Anwendung
da draus und packen
alles in eine Executable rein.
So, und das Executable will ich
jetzt ja hier im Ordner liegen haben.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
mal gucken,
ob das von uns,
wenn wir mal nebenbei drauf schauen,
ob Windows fertig ist.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir könnten eigentlich
uns was abgucken
von dem Docker-File hier.
genau das da weil dann sollten wir im endeffekt nur einen container image
bekommen wo nichts anderes drin ist als unser executable
Wie habe ich das genannt?
Build CLI
Und da sind wir unter
Workdir
Slash Build
Bin mir nicht sicher wo das denn rauskommt
Ehrlich gesagt
Kann man das so machen?
Locker Bild und dann sagen Output hier.
Schauen wir mal.
Gucken wir was unsere Windows Installation macht.
Der ist ein bisschen lahm, hä?
Was macht denn der da so lang?
Der Extracted.
Doku schreiben ist out.
du kannst die vibe coden
deine Doku
schreib dann sowas heute noch
außerdem der viel bessere Ansatz
ich hab das ja schon ein paar mal gesagt ist
solange alles fehlerfrei funktioniert
first try braucht man keine Doku
und auch keine Kommentare
und auch keine ordentlichen Commit Messages
weil es geht ja alles
einfach immer fehlerfrei
Was man da für Geld spart?
Was?
From S-Casing
S and from Keywords
Casing do not match.
Wie, was matcht nicht?
Das habe ich doch aus dem schon bestehenden
Docker-File rauskopiert. Wie kann da was nicht matchen?
Was will er denn?
Ist es so? Ne.
Was will er von mir?
Das ist ein Warning.
Einmal groß und einmal klein?
Ach so.
Ah.
Was meint er mit
Casing? Okay.
Da sind wir doch.
Hier, Bild.
Siehelei, da ist es doch.
Okay, cool.
Das Funds, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Jetzt können wir die Anwendung bauen.
Und die kommt hier in diesem Bildverzeichnis raus.
Das ist doch nice.
Die kann man dann hier ausführen.
vm champ das hat ein bisschen doofer name nicht der vm champ
ich habe ist gebildet ist aber auch wurscht so prinzipiell funks das was ich mir da überlegt habe
Gut, dann gucken wir mal unsere Windows-Installation mittlerweile durch jetzt.
So.
Ja, jetzt ist es auch ein bisschen weniger.
Ja, da ist es. Nice.
Sehr schön.
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
Jetzt funzt das
Jetzt haben wir eine Self-Contain-Anwendung über Docker gebaut
Und dann wieder aus dem Container rauskopiert
So ist das schön
So
Also
Guck mal was unsere Windows installt
Ich mein, die Windows waren auch gar nicht fertig
Oh ne
Fuck, ich hab vergessen
Muss man nicht das Netzwerkkabel entfernen
Dafür, dass wir das ordentlich installieren dürften
da gibt es trick 17
ich habe mir vorgenommen wieder ein bisschen mehr zu streamen
chat wenn ich menschen sachen mal über sehe schreibt einfach noch mal hier mit
entwurf los in den chat reicht das wenn ich jetzt das netzwerkkabel trenne
disconnect yes germany input method übrigens mal ernsthaft wer hat eigentlich dieses ding
hier programmiert dieses schrott menü wo man nicht mal g drücken kann um zu
germany zu kommen das ist so unterirdisch schlecht
Okay.
Jetzt gibt es doch irgendwie, was muss man?
F12? Shift? F12?
Ja. Was? OOB muss man jetzt
irgendwie irgendwas in der Richtung machen, oder?
Warte mal. Ich will nur mal
sicherstellen, dass ich auch in der VM bin.
Jetzt nicht hier irgendwie auf meinem System oder so.
OOBE?
Oder irgendwie sowas hier.
OO... Ne. Ah, fuck.
Keine Ahnung mehr, wie das funzt.
Da muss ich nachgucken.
Windows 11 install without Microsoft Account.
Der Chat weiß es auswendig.
Okay, ich glaube euch das mal.
OOBE.
Bypass.
NRO.
Falsch, Chat.
Ach, es ist ein Backslash.
Wir sind ja unter Windows.
Ah, Alter.
Heck, wait.
Oh, jetzt starten sie.
Chat, ich hole mir kurz was zu trinken.
So.
Und jetzt geht das jetzt, oder wie?
Warum fängt der Mist eigentlich wieder von vorne an?
Was ist der Plan heute?
Exakt das, was im Titel steht.
Versuchen,
VeraCrip mit SecureBoot zum Laufen zu bekommen,
da ich Battlefiend sehr gestipuliert kann.
Skip.
Und?
I don't have Internet!
Da ist der Knopf.
Es ist eigentlich schon echt lächerlich,
dass es so ein Act ist, oder?
What's your name?
Fuck.
Microsoft.
Enter Passwort 123456.
Massive Passwort 123456.
Question!
Eins, zwei, drei.
Ach, jetzt kommt der Lisa ganz im Mist.
No.
Es gibt ja nicht No, es gibt ja nur Required.
Getting things ready for you.
Na dann.
mach dich ready für uns.
Warum brauchst du
Vera Crypt für Battlefield 6?
Ich brauche nicht Vera Crypt für Battlefield 6.
Ich habe Vera Crypt und Battlefield 6
hat keinen Bock da drauf.
Weil ich
deswegen kein Secure Boot habe.
Battlefield 6 habe ich installiert.
Habe ich gestartet.
und dann hat das Anti-Cheat zu mir gesagt,
keck, geh.
Das geht nicht, weil kein Secure Boot.
So sieht's aus.
Ich will das nicht als Domainrechner einrichten.
Ich hab doch kein AD daheim.
Wo kommt man denn dahin?
Das gebe ich mir nicht.
Da muss man sich ja irgendwie mit Windows-Gedöns auseinandersetzen.
Im Leben nicht.
So.
Schön, dass wenn kein Internetzugang besteht,
die halbe Taskleiste leer ist, oder?
Auch geil.
Sag mal, wie hässlich...
Jetzt mal seriously.
Wie hässlich kann man es eigentlich machen?
Ernsthaft.
A great app is on its way.
Candy Crush.
Okay, so.
Gib wieder Internetzugang.
Connect.
OM.
Install Tools.
Und dann machen wir einen Snapshot, Leute.
Ich installiere noch einen Browser.
Copilot.
Kann man das aninstallen?
Moment.
Ich will, dass es weg geht.
Wie kriege ich das weg?
Please.
Ah, remove.
Remove.
Programs.
Ja, Copilot.
Also.
Okay.
Das schon mal weg.
So.
Taskbar Settings.
Widgets aus.
Search.
Hide.
Funktioniert.
Und jetzt hätte ich gerne.
Left.
Und dann.
Never
Gut
So
Immerhin, jetzt kann man das halbwegs benutzen
Jetzt nehmen wir noch
VMware Tools, dass wir das Ganze nicht
Äh
Was?
Was muss ich denn davon jetzt starten?
Kann man nicht einfach irgendwie sagen
Install? Ne, gibt's nicht
Ja, wahrscheinlich muss ich Setup 64 starten.
Stimmt, wo sind eigentlich die Sekunden?
Gab es das nicht mal?
Hatten die das nicht mal hinzugefügt, dass man Sekunden anzeigen lassen kann?
Das ging doch mal, oder?
Ja, wo würden wir denn da hinkommen,
wenn die Settings für die Uhr
auch im Uhr-Settings-Dialog
wären?
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Du musst das ausklappen.
Moment, mein Fenster ist noch nicht groß genug.
Wir gucken mal.
Gucken mal.
Windows 11
Show seconds in clock.
How to show seconds in taskbar.
taskbar behavior seconds jetzt ist das ist das wirklich den ernst die sec die
settings für die sekunden von der uhr stehen nicht in den uhr settings sondern in den taskbar
settings was sie denkt die sich das ist doch komplett ohne plan was da passiert
Wir starten noch nicht, also Taskbar Settings
Und jetzt
Taskbar Behavior war das?
Ne
Äh
Wo?
Wo muss ich hin?
Gibt es da mehr oder?
Ne, das glaube ich nicht, dass ich Windows erst aktivieren muss.
Was gibt es da mehr?
Steht doch oben da
Oh
You need to activate
Ja dann ist es ausgegraut aber der Button ist noch nicht weg
Das ist das gleiche wie wenn ich hier sage
Personalize
Dass das nicht richtig funktioniert
wenn ich hier was einstellen wenn dann geht sich aber die die settings sind da
uhrzeit einstellung show time and date in taskbar aufklappen okay
uhrzeit du meinst dass hier uhrzeit settings
Schau, Timer, Date, Interest, Return,
das Off, halt.
Ne, da ist die Uhr ganz weg.
Okay, halten wir fest.
Es geht nicht mehr,
die Sekunden anzeigen zu lassen.
Was können wir machen?
Seconds.
Ach das kann man aufklappen
Alter dieses Menü
Oh man
Alter
Was ein Schrott
So, aber jetzt kommen wir zur eigentlichen Sache
Also, wir müssen jetzt gucken,
ob ich die richtige Reihenfolge einhalte
So, wir installieren jetzt erst mal schnell Firefox.
Oh, wenn...
Ah!
What the fuck is happening?
Es ist mir doch egal, wie Edge aussieht.
Nee, ich will es auf Englisch runterladen.
Kann man hier, kann man, kann man sagen?
E-N?
Ja.
Stimmt, Winged.
Du hast recht.
Das wäre eine gute Idee.
Das probieren wir jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein.
Geh weg.
Cancel.
Winged.
Achtung.
Win.
Win get.
Moment, meine Shell hängt.
Ich kann nichts mehr löschen.
Win get.
Was? Uni get?
Nee.
Win get.
Ähm.
Search.
Huh?
Search Firefox.
Ja, ja ich agree.
Okay, wie dumm will man eine Paketverwaltung machen?
Microsoft dachte, jo wir können das, noch schlimmer.
Ich seh was, die können mich mal.
Nehmen das was ich runtergeladen habe, den Firefox Installer.
es ist sehr gut
wenn get install mozilla.de fox.de
Okay.
Ja, mach.
Was? Yes, mach.
Okay.
Google.
Okay, da sind wir.
Gut, also.
Veracrypt. Jetzt mache ich einen Snapshot.
Ich habe keinen Bock,
das nochmal machen zu müssen, wenn ich irgendwas verpacke.
Winutil
Okay, was ist das?
Warum gibt es da schon wieder 3000 Sachen?
Ich mach das jetzt, was ist Winutil?
Ich geb das jetzt mal gleich ein
Zack
Erstmal warten, bis der Snapshot hat
Gesnapshottet
Terminal
Winutil
Gibt's nicht
Denied
VeraCrypt Downloads
Hat VeraCrypt nicht auch GitHub mittlerweile?
Doch
Releases
Ja
Alter, 126 Assets
Krasses Zeug
Gibt es da irgendwas wie Windows vielleicht?
Äh
Exe, da.
Okay.
Accepted die Lizenzterms.
Install.
Mach.
Jawoll, successfully installed.
Finish.
No, wir wollen kein Tutorial.
tutorial macht auch nichts mehr auf youtube so wäre crypt da ist es sagt da sind wir so system
und jetzt wollen wir ein krypt system partition yes normal klingt gut ein krypt windows system
partition klingen klingt auch okay single boot ist okay passwort super komplexes passwort mal
jetzt 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 ja ja so wir sammeln randomness leute massive randomness
wird gesammelt so sammelt man randomness falls ihr euch immer gefragt habt wo die randoms random
sachen überall herkommen die generiere ich jetzt für die ganze welt wird randomness generiert wir
Wir farmen Randomness.
Wenn irgendwo mal Random
nicht richtig funktioniert, liegt es daran, dass ich meine Maus
hier nicht random genug bewegt habe.
Okay. Randomness
ist gefarmt.
Next.
Ich will da nichts rescuen.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, Vera Crypt.
Du hast ja recht. Da wird auch nichts
gewiped. Test. So.
Okay. Restart.
So, jetzt muss ich ein Passwort eingeben beim Restart
Mein Lieblingsrandom ist den Lavalampen
Ja, da gab es doch mal irgendwas
Jetzt wo du es sagst, ich erinnere mich
Hat da nicht irgendwie einer mal mit Lavalampen
So einen Randomness-Generator gebaut?
Oder, nee, Cloudflare war das
Cloudflare war das mit Lavalampen, ja
Da habe ich noch was drüber gelesen
Weißt du, wie haben die das gemacht?
mit irgendeiner
Image-Erkennung dann.
Die erzeugen Randomness
mit Lava-Lampen.
Win Util ist ein Skript.
Achso, ich dachte, das standen wir sich drauf.
Ja, ne, dann extra installieren.
Pre-Test has been successful.
Encrypt. Okay.
Yes.
Dann encrypten wir mal.
Das geht relativ schnell.
Ein Video von
Wann von Lava Lampen. Ja, ich hab das mal gelesen.
Äh, hängt Windows gerade?
Chatge?
Chat, Windows hängt.
Das liegt bestimmt.
Ich hätt gesagt, das ist bestimmt
der Antivirus, der hängt.
ähm
ah, Anti-Mailware-Services
hängt, ja siehste
willst du
Belfina FM testen oder was?
ich will testen, wie ich Veracrypt mit
Secure Boot zum Laufen kriege und dann
lasse ich das auf meinem Desktop so laufen
ich esse mal übrigens ein Brötchen nebenbei
Alter
Was macht das?
Ich brauche halt 3 Stunden.
Was Veracrypt mit Battlefield 6 zu tun hat?
Battlefield 6 braucht für den Anti-Cheat Secure Boot.
Ich habe mein System voll verschlüsselt mit Veracrypt.
Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie gucken, wie ich Veracrypt mit Secure Boot zum Laufen kriege,
dass ich Battlefield 6 spielen kann.
Was macht das Ding eigentlich?
Chat, meint ihr, das geht irgendwann nochmal weiter?
Oder das hängt jetzt unendlich im Windows Defender?
Was spricht gegen BitLocker?
Was BitLocker bei mir schon seit Release unten durch ist,
weil das erste über BitLocker, was ich gelesen habe, ist,
dass man, wenn man sein Passwort vergessen hat,
das irgendwie restauren kann.
Und das finde ich irgendwie
per Default, äh, per Design
irgendwie unsicher.
Ah, guck mal!
Geht weiter.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist es pausiert.
Okay, das geht relativ schnell jetzt.
Hier, zwei Minuten, drei Minuten.
erforderlich war mein brötchen weiter
der restore geht nur mit microsoft konto ja kann sein
das nächste ist mit locker ist nicht open source wäre kommt schon als würde
ich da auf vera crypt mehr verlassen dass das ordentlich ist als mit locker
du hast secure boot an wenn du battlefield 6 spielen konntest wir werden
gleich sehen ob das ohne probleme geht probieren aus
ach ja was habt ihr chat das ist jetzt wichtig die die geschrieben haben es
funktioniert. Könnt ihr mir sagen, was ihr für eine
Vera-Crypt-Version verwendet?
Leute, ich bin übrigens
total hängen geblieben. Ich habe die falsche
Vera-Crypt-Version installiert.
Ich restore mal den Snapshot.
1, 2, 5, 9.
Die habe ich auch.
1, 2, 5, 9 habe ich auch.
Keine Beta gespielt?
Ne, konnte ja nicht, wegen Secure Boot.
vielleicht hätte ich die beta spielen können uns funzt alles immer gleich
yes yes no und jetzt
das ganze noch mal schnell klicken
ein massives passwort wie genug randomness collected
naja ich weiß dass man das nicht skippen sollte aber ich gebe das trotzdem test okay
Yes, restart
Nutzt du die Version wegen TrueCrypt?
Ne, ich nutze die Version, weil ich die bei mir installiert habe
Und ich habe die bei mir installiert, weil es damals noch nichts Neues gab
Deswegen will ich gucken, ob es damit funzt
Wenn nicht, upgrade ich das?
Ne, ne, Dante
Die meisten Leute haben ja das Problem nicht
Die meisten Leute benutzen ja kein Veracrypt
also ich kann den battle für die leute wenig vorwürfe machen ich verstehe auch in irgendeiner
art und weise dass das sinnvoll ist für antizipit secure boot zu entforcen
Also Vera Clip Upgraden hatte ich noch nie Probleme mit.
Ich hoffe das dauert jetzt nicht mehr so lange.
Hört ihr eigentlich, dass ich schmatze?
oder hört man nichts vom essen
nur wenn du abweißt okay dann ist gut weil ich finde eating sounds selbst
nicht sonderlich geil ich weiß manche leute stehen da richtig drauf aber ich
bin ich so der eating sounds fan
was denn
Ach, das sind Johannisbeeren.
Okay.
Ist das ein Stuhl? Ne.
Jetzt muss ich aufpassen, dass ich mein
Headset-Mikro nicht da rein tauche.
Wenn wir schon von Fetisch reden, hast du einen neuen Anime, den du schaust?
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe gerade angefangen einen zu gucken, wenn ich der große Anime gucke.
Aber ich bin da das letzte Jahr über ein bisschen auf den Geschmack gekommen, weil mir die ganzen Streaming-Services auf den Sack gehen.
Und die meisten Animes kannst du ohne
Subscription gucken
Äh, ja
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie es heißt
Da geht's ums Fahrradfahren
Das ist wirklich
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung
Wie man
Mehr Anime-Style
Sowas wie Radrennen machen kann
Also so nach dem Motto
Er geht aus dem Sattel
Oh nein, er geht aus dem Sattel
Zack, zack, Splitscreen
so nach dem motto 25 25 minuten mit irgendwie 100 meter gefahren oder so was ich bin das heißt
irgendwas mit pedal heißt dieser anime irgendwas mit pedal irgendwie japan langes japanisches wort
pedal und und was da auch gelernt habe ist wenn man den berg hoch fährt ja genau das ist es genau
das ist es jo war muschi pedal klingel wie unanständig ja das ist es genau was ich auch
gelernt habe ist wenn man den berg hoch fährt also was ich dort auch gelernt habe wenn man den berg
hoch fährt und man schafft das nicht den berg hoch zu fahren da muss man den den wie heißt
das auf deutsch den den könnte man das übersetzen ich habe das irgendwie liebes
prinzessin oder so die liebes prinzessin song singen dann fährt man viel schneller
den berg hoch also ich habe gelernt heim heißt prinzessin auf japanisch das ist
eines der wenigen wörter die ich durch mein anime gucken gelernt habe
ja genau das ist das ich will euch jetzt nicht quälen damit für alle nicht anime
schauer
Ja...
So, gleich haben wir fertig
encryptet.
Und, fertig
encrypted? 100%,
aber gut. Da sind wir auch
bei Windows gewöhnt. 100% heißt noch
nicht lange fertig.
Jetzt kommt bestimmt wieder der Windows Defender
eigentlich. Da ist er doch schon.
da ist auch schon der windows defender der windows defender ist nicht damit
einverstanden dass meine festplatte verschlüsselt wird
mario das ist nice zu hören sieht man mal wie lange ich eigentlich schon am stream
so und bin kommt mir gar nicht so lange vor ist aber schon dann
wenn sie statt dann finaler switch zu linux desktop das ding ist die jungs
bringt ja auch nichts in dem fall
Weil ganze Anti-Cheat-Geschichten funzen nicht.
Der Rest geht ja ganz brauchbar mittlerweile.
Aber Anti-Cheat kannst du halt knicken.
ne konsole habe ich kein wort mehr drauf auf windows defender kommt gibt alles
aber irgendwie ausschalten
siehst du noch radfahren und joggen durch nein letzter zeit ein bisschen weniger
wieder und schaltet man denn die windows defender aus hier
manage settings das daher
nice sehr gut jetzt kommen wir einschalten jetzt kommen wir
wieder jetzt kommen wir einschalten weil nur für den kurze zeit herr
successfully be encrypted finish dann rebooten wir mal gucken ob es noch funktioniert
und dann schalte ich secure boot ein das muss jetzt funktionieren
ok von st
Okay.
Shutdown?
Jetzt machen wir Secure Boot an.
Auf Windows, Shutdown.
Was ist denn das da unten eigentlich?
Achso.
Als ich eine outdated Vmware Version habe.
Das weiß ich selbst.
das war jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wie das funst einfach wie wie das geht nee oder was das geht einfach das heißt
ich hätte die Battlefield 6 Beta spielen können.
Wait a minute.
Damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet, dass das geht.
Das tut, das fun...
Hä? Ich habe überall gelesen,
Secure Boot und Veraclip funktionieren nicht zusammen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wir müssen mal gucken,
ob wir wirklich Secure Boot haben.
ja warum geht das warum steht überall das nicht funktioniert und sollte es
nicht gehen weil ich dachte der wäre für bootloader ist nicht gesandt das würde
ja heißen dass wenn ich bei mir im bios secure boot einschalte dass es dann
einfach instant geht sich das richtig
das heißt auch ich hätte es einschalten können die battle für sechs meter spielen
anstatt das nicht zu machen und das zu ignorieren
wieso hast du nicht einfach eingeschaltet und geschaut weil ich davon überzeugt war es geht nicht
Ich habe extra nachgeguckt.
Es gibt es sogar auf dem Veracrypt
Subreddit
Einträge mit funktioniert nicht.
Guckt hier.
Ja, zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Will enabling Secure Boot cause problems for Veracrypt?
Yes.
Geht nicht.
Veracrypt Bootloader doesn't work with Secure Boot.
You cannot boot.
Warum willst du Veracrypt eigentlich?
Weil ich Veracrypt seit Jahren schon lange hab.
System.
Aha.
Wisst ihr, was sein kann, Leute?
Guckt mal.
Ne, das ist genau das gleiche.
System Partition, System Partition.
Also das ist hier mein...
vom...
das heißt es funzt einfach wenn ich jetzt im bios einschalte okay das war die battlefield
entwickler die haben getrollt ah ja klar ja okay chat gilt das ist dann okay dann machen wir jetzt
noch ein upgrade vera crypt da machen wir jetzt noch ein upgrade auf die neueste version
gucken ob das noch funzt
Kann UEFI und BIOS Boot noch reinspielen?
Ja, aber das hier ist UEFI Boot.
EFI Boot?
Woran sieht man das, ob man EFI Boot...
Ah hier, BIOS Mode, UEFI.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich euch das bei mir zeigen will.
Biosmode OEFI habe ich bei mir auch.
Ab VeraCrypt 1.62 ist der Bootloader von Microsoft signiert.
Ich habe 1.259, es ging trotzdem.
So, jetzt machen wir nochmal ein Upgrade auf das neueste VeraCrypt, weil ab und zu mal
upgrade sich verkehrt die zertifikate im moment die kubu zertifikate können
ablaufen ja gut sind zertifikate
upgrade
ja mach mal ein icon auf desktop ist okay
mal gucken ob jetzt der windows defender wiederum spackt
ok das kommt das mache ich dann für mein eigentliches system
wenn ich wie start
erst das ist ja easy also wenn das jetzt echt alles gewesen ist dann weiß ich
mir wirklich in arsch dass die battlefield 6 beta nicht gespielt habe
ja
Ja, Leute.
Es ist...
Es gibt Schäden, Zeichen und Wunder.
Das ist auch mal was einfacher als gedacht.
Was hat hier mein Netzwerkkabel gerade für Schmerzen?
No Internet Access.
Oh.
Nein, nein, nein.
Warum sagt er, dass ich kein Internet Access habe?
Das ist doch kompletter Blödsinn.
Ich habe Internet-Access, das sieht man doch hier
Das ist, okay, Windows
Windows-Logik
Warum habe ich keine, ach jetzt, ne
Angeblich habe ich kein
Internet, sagt meine VM
Was ist denn, wenn ich sage Disconnect
und Connect
Dann geht's
Logisch, natürlich, was sonst
Ja gut, Chat
Dann hat sich das
deutlich einfacher rausgestellt, als gedacht
hätte haben wir noch irgendeine youtube video was gucken könnte bis 18 bis 19 uhr aber noch
irgendwas spannendes jetzt haben wir schon alles geguckt frankfurt hauptbahnhof drogen
gewalt und warf wie krass ist der job war okay ich will mal kurz reingucken ja da bin ich heute
Genau da bin ich heute vorbeigelaufen.
Ah ja, die üblichen Verdächtigen wieder.
Prügeleien am Gleis.
Okay, komm.
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Wie viele Waffen hattest du dabei?
Also Waffen im eigentlichen Sinne natürlich nicht.
Was ich dabei habe ist,
Das zählt aber nicht als Waffe.
Ich habe ein Taschenmesser.
Ne, das stimmt noch nicht mal.
Ha, das ist kein Taschenmesser.
Es ist eine Pfeile und eine kleine Schere.
Ist es.
Habe ich dabei.
Ich habe so eine, so eine, so im Visitenkartenformat.
So eine, so ein Tool.
So ein Mini-Toolset quasi dabei.
so mit, ähm,
warte mal, ich zeige euch das mal.
Das ist sogar richtig prachlich, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal
gebraucht.
Ich muss mal kurz nur bei mir auf dem Handy gucken.
Ähm,
wie das hieß.
Was, wenn ich noch Schere suche, vielleicht?
Ah ja, hier, Victorinox.
Ja, das ist es.
Swiss Card, Pocket, okay.
Victory Logs, Swiss Card, Classic.
So ein Ding hier ist das, was ich da dabei habe.
Guck, da ist nur, dass ich das mit der Pfeile habe.
Wobei, vielleicht habe ich doch ein Messer drin.
Passt auch, Leute hier, super, super gefährlich.
Bin ich für Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof gewappnet mit diesem Messer, hä?
Das Teil habe ich dabei.
Und das ist echt praktisch.
Ich habe das schon ein paar Mal gebraucht auf der Arbeit.
Wenn ich morgens festgestellt habe, irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Augenbraue hängt schief oder so, muss weg.
Oder irgendwie Fingernagel eingerissen und sowas.
Und dann bin ich ja auch für die Messerstecherei im Hauptbahnhof gerüstet hiermit.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lang die Klinge ist.
0,3 cm Klinge oder so.
Ja.
Halbe Ätzjurk.
Okay, schauen wir mal,
was in Frankfurt so abgeht.
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Kriminalität, Gewalt und Drogen
gehören hier zum Alltag.
Ich hatte ein Körperverletzungsdelikt
vor einigen Jahren.
By the way, in diesen Beiträgen
sieht es oftmals so aus, als ist es ganz
furchtbar lebensgefährlich, Frankfurt am Hauptbahnhof
unterwegs zu sein. Ist es nicht.
Ja? Gibt
Schlimmeres.
Ich bin genau hier heute.
Genau hier.
Wobei,
das war da nicht.
Heute vorbei.
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Kriminalität,
Gewalt und Drogen gehören hier zum
Alltag.
Ich hatte ein Körperverletzungsdelikt vor einigen Jahren.
Ein Mann mit einer abgebrochenen Glasflasche.
Ist das laut genug?
... quasi den Hals gestochen wurde.
An Deutschlands Bahnhöfen soll die Bundespolizei für unsere Sicherheit sorgen.
Also ich sehe wenig Polizisten im Hauptbahnhof. Ich sehe da immer nur die Bahnsecurity rumlaufen.
Davor jede Menge immer.
Heute auch nur davor.
... begeben sich die Beamten dabei selbst in Gefahr.
Was wir halt erleben ist, dass mehr und mehr Messer mitgeführt werden oder Pfefferspray.
Das gehört eigentlich schon so zur Grundausstattung fast.
Dieses Wochenende bin ich nicht nur dabei, sondern mittendrin.
99 für Lea bei Personen.
Ich darf selbst Personen kontrollieren und nach gefährlichen Gegenständen suchen.
Also Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, eins muss man ja sagen, die Dichte an wirklich fertigen Leuten ist da sehr hoch.
Es kam auch eine Meldung, dass eine Person einen gefährlichen Gegenstand dabei haben soll.
In dieser Reportage möchte ich herausfinden, wie viel der Job bei der Bundespolizei wirklich abverlangt.
Gleich ist Schichtbeginn hier am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof bei der Bundespolizei.
Und ich darf die diese...
Guckt das eigentlich nur, dass ich ein paar fertige Leute, dass ihr auch mal ein paar fertige Leute sehen könnt vom Hauptbahnhof.
Die drei Bundespolizisten Dennis, Dominik und Tizia nehmen mich heute mit auf Streife.
Alle drei sind schon über fünf Jahre mit dabei.
Die Tizian gibt mir erstmal...
Ey, das sieht aus wie Polizeirevier.
Was war das?
Ich hab's vergessen.
Da musste ich mal hin.
Ich weiß, wo das ist.
Das ist, wenn die Gutleutstraße immer weiterläuft.
Ja, und dann, keine Ahnung, kann ich das...
Da musste ich mal hin.
Mein Chef wurde mal überfallen am Hauptbahnhof.
Mein alter in der alten Firma.
mein chef wurde mal überfallen und dem haben sie das geld sein geld geklaut und nach ein paar tagen
haben sie den kram wiedergefunden und er hat mich zum polizeirevier 1 nee keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
sehen wie durchnummeriert zu dem polizeirevier das genau so aus zum polizeirevier geschickt um
um sein Geld zu holen.
Mal eine Schutzweste.
Eine Schutzweste.
Der wird ordentlich warm.
Der wird sehr warm.
Ich glaube, Wärme ist das kleinste Problem.
Vor was schützt die alles?
Die schützt vor Stichen.
Da ist ein Stichschutz drin,
um zu projektieren mit 9 mm.
Außerdem bekomme ich ein Funkgerät,
um mit den anderen in Kontakt zu bleiben.
Das ist klassisch,
Das ist klassisch, wenn ihr Verstärkung braucht, dann sprecht ihr hier rein.
Oder wenn irgendwas passiert, meldet ihr.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Und wurde auch noch nicht kontrolliert.
Alter, was für eine Musik da im Hintergrund am Start ist.
Du musst ja jetzt uns noch rausmelden.
Ich finde es crazy, dass du das einfach bekommen hast. Warum?
Der hat ja mit denen wohl schon im Vorfeld besprochen, das Ganze.
Die schicken jetzt hier einen Azubi vorbei.
Also ist schon ein bisschen her, ne?
Wir sind ja jetzt im Bahnhof und da müssen wir ja oben der Leitstelle den Kollegen mitteilen,
dass wir praktisch jetzt im Bahnhof sind.
Deswegen funkt jetzt einfach Leitstelle.
Ja, das will ich alles nicht sehen.
Juckt mich nicht.
Interessiert mich auch nicht.
Ich will eigentlich nur gucken.
Personenkontrolle und Drogenfonds.
Okay, dafür.
Und dann geht es auch gleich schon zur ersten Personenkontrolle.
Ein junger Mann mit Kippen im Rauchverbot.
Die sehen bestimmt schon typisch fertig aus, wie am Hauptbahnhof halt die Leute so aussehen.
Noch schaue ich nur zu. Später darf ich dann selbst ran.
Wobei, der sieht auf den ersten Blick noch relativ normal aus.
Hören Sie mal hier bitte. Stellen Sie sich mal bitte hin.
Haben Sie mal einen Ausweis dabei?
Wobei, nee, der sieht nicht normal aus. Was hat der denn da über dem Kopf hängen?
Hören Sie mal hier bitte.
Der hat irgendwas über dem Kopf hängen. Das ist doch schon mal verdächtig.
Was hat er denn jetzt allgestellt, der Fabio?
Noch fühle ich mich ziemlich unwohl in dieser Rolle.
Okay, also Ausschreibende Behörde, das Amtsgericht Frankfurt am Main.
Ja, aber das weißt du ja, hast du uns gesagt. Kannst du jetzt gehen.
Bei diesem Mann läuft eine Aufenthaltsermittlung.
Heißt, Behörden versuchen zu ermitteln, wo er sich aufhält.
Bei einer Kontrolle muss ihn die Polizei aufklären, dass wie in diesem Fall das Gericht nach ihm sucht.
Hä?
Ist die Person euch jetzt schon von weitem aufgefallen?
Das ist diese gebeugte Haltung, das ist dieses bisschen Versteckte, dieses ich will nicht
auffallen, schwarze Kapuze, dann das halt mit der Zigarette, das sind alles so kleine
Anhaltspunkte, die man irgendwann zusammen puzzelt und dann entscheidet man sich für
eine Personenkontrolle.
Wann die Polizei eine Kontrolle durchführen darf, erfahrt ihr später noch.
Und auch, was sie zu Racial Profiling sagen.
Oh please!
Können wir nicht einfach mal ohne irgendwelche kritischen Themen sich was angucken?
Dann fallen meiner Streife direkt die nächsten Verdächtigen ins Auge.
Ja.
Sorry.
Einmal zusammenpacken.
Oh, da haben sie die üblichen Verdächtigen aber schon am Start.
Ich glaube, ich weiß sogar, wo das ist.
Das ist entweder dieses Ding, wo du zwischen den Gleisen gehst.
Oder es ist, wenn du runtergehst, also da, wo die eben waren.
Geradeaus weiter
geht es rechts rum.
Da, wo früher die Apotheke
war.
Und dann, wo die Treppe wieder hoch geht.
Auf der...
Ist hier Münchnerstraße?
Ich glaube, auf der Münchnerstraße.
Diese Personen
haben scheinbar Drogen konsumiert.
Aber nur der Besitz
von Drogen ist strafbar.
Ja, ja.
Ist es. Relativ sicher.
Das ist noch die alte Ecke, da wurde nichts umgebaut.
Weil davor ist es ja relativ neu.
Da wurde ja...
Am Hauptbahnhof, dieses Untergrundding,
sieht jetzt viel schicker aus.
Das sind bis jetzt eigentlich nur Drogen.
Also ich finde die Leute überhaupt nicht bedrohlich oder so.
Ich finde eher, also die wirken ein bisschen verloren.
Die beiden dürfen gehen.
Auf unserem Streifzug erzählt mir Dennis,
was er in über fünf dienstjahren unter anderem als als einer meiner ersten tage wo ich da
gearbeitet habe in frankfurt wenn ich in meinen kollegen zum mittagessen gegangen
kann ich euch sogar zeigen wo apps google frankfurt
so und da gibt es
metzger göbel oder so hieß der fleischerei
So.
Und hier daneben ist ein Waschsalon.
Und in der Tür vom Waschsalon stand einer gegen die Türrahmen gelehnt.
Und ich laufe an dem vorbei, der grinst mich so an.
Und ich denke mir schon so, was hat er denn? Warum grinst er denn so?
Und dann gucke ich mir den ein bisschen genauer an.
Und in dem Moment holt er, oder hat er wahrscheinlich schon die Spritze in der Hand und drückt die sich in den Arm rein.
Es war eines der ersten Sachen, die ich mir nach so in Frankfurt gesehen habe.
Auf mich zum Mittagessen.
Erstmal ein Typ, zack.
Ein Kollege von mir hat dann noch zu ihm gesagt, Mahlzeit.
Ja, RF-Programmer, Mahlzeit, hat auch einer gesagt.
Der hat aber wahrscheinlich nichts davon mitgekriegt.
So, mal reingucken.
Angriff mit Glasflasche, okay.
... schon alles erlebt hat.
Ich hatte einen Körperverletzungs-
Sag mir, der erzählt nur.
Ich will doch... Prügelei am Kleist, okay.
In einem Zug wurde ein Päckchen mit weißem Pulver gefunden.
Unter Anleitung soll ich einen Drogentest durchführen.
Doch dann erlebe ich zum ersten Mal, wie schnell hier manchmal alles gehen kann.
Sitzgelegenheit, rückwärts zu sprechen.
Er ist da.
Sollen wir mitkommen?
Ja, okay.
Und das war's.
Und wir rennen.
Bleib mal da stehen.
Just stand still here, okay?
Yes.
Keep calm and everything is right, okay?
I come, I went here.
It's okay.
I come Germany.
Und er kam Germany und das erste, was er macht, ist immer eine Runde prügeln oder was?
Wir können uns eigentlich gerade in die Dienststelle in Drogen testen und dann kam direkt der Funk, dass sich zwei Leute prügeln, hier bei der Sitzecke.
Und ich verstehe noch nicht 100% was passiert ist, aber es werden gerade zwei Passanten jetzt befragt und die Personendaten aufgeführt.
Ach da ist ja eine...
Ich glaube, das ist ein...
Da gibt es nicht so viel wirklich
zu gucken.
Ich dachte, wir können uns ein bisschen fertige Leute
am Hauptbahnhof angucken.
Es gab ja mal ein Video von mir, das hieß ja auch
fertige Leute am Hauptbahnhof, glaube ich.
Äh,
wollen wir uns nicht angucken.
So, ich habe jetzt noch drei Stück Apfel, die futter ich jetzt noch
Ich habe da eigentlich schon von genug
Wenn ich am Hauptbahnhof bin
Ich muss mir das eigentlich gar nicht mehr
Ich gucke da gar nicht mehr richtig hin
Ehrlich gesagt
Aber manchmal geht es halt nicht anders
Zum Beispiel, wenn einer wie ein Flugzeug an dir vorbeifliegt
Da ist ein Typ, der rennt manchmal rum
Die Straße lang
Wie so ein Flieger
Und macht dabei
Und so mit Armen ausgebreitet
Fliegt der da rum
Das ist wahrscheinlich immer, wenn der sich
Irgendwas reingeschmissen hat oder so
So Leute, hast du da halt
Den Massen
aber da muss sagen das klientel am hauptbahnhof ist anders wie noch vor ein paar jahren früher
war zum größten teil irgendwelche sommer penner und drogenabhängige oder beides in kombination
Das war hier der größte Teil.
Heute ist gerade, wenn du
Hauptbahnhof
Richtung Platz der Republik
rausgehst,
in die Richtung,
das ist wirklich halb Afrika.
Mittlerweile.
Also alles
ist wirklich wie
Afrika, wenn du da rausgehst.
An der Stelle sind kaum noch
Drogenabhängige und Fertige.
Da sieht es eher aus wie Afrika.
Oh, Pilot, wenn du ein Flugzeug sein kannst.
Der Kerl ist wahrscheinlich auch gerade in seinem Kopf ein Flugzeug.
Die Aussage soll nicht komisch sein, das ist dann so.
Wenn du da rausgehst, guck dich da mal um.
Das ist nicht mehr wie früher, wo quasi der Hauptbahnhof komplett bevölkert war, draußen rum rum quasi.
Wo Drogenabhängige und Obdachlose rumgehangen haben.
Gerade Richtung Platz der Republik, das ist wirklich, wie kommst du hervor, als bist du in Afrika.
er trägt für die pilotausbildung da wirst du die man nicht die machen ich
hast man euro da wirst du teilweise so komisch von der seite an ange an
gegensatz so hier guck mal guck mal die manche komische geräusche da immer zu
gucken guck mal ganz wert weiß gar nicht was die wollen ich wollte irgendwas
aufschwätzen oder so
alle mal ein einmal einer wollte dass ich an einem schließfach im bahnhof was
für ihn hole da habe ich mir auch gedacht ja ganz bestimmt einer ganz
bestimmt man wer weiß was da drin ist
ja die zeit steht schon davor
naja die windows vor dem löschen oder brauchen wir die noch mal
dafür brauchen die nicht mehr egal ich lass dir noch mal da also halbe stunde zeit habe
ich noch leute habt ihr irgendwie guten video vorschlag oder irgendwas oder irgendein thema
wollte noch irgendwas wissen soll ich mich über jeden fall auslassen weil ich bin jetzt ich bin
jetzt eigentlich durch mit web support und mainz in 30 minuten mit rast oder
rast wie weit wenn schon blazing fast
battlefield
Wann kommt Battlefield jetzt eigentlich genau raus?
Das ist doch gar nicht mehr lang, oder?
25. oder sowas?
10. Oktober.
Ja, das ist ja bald.
Das ist genau noch ein Monat.
Aber 10. Oktober, da gibt es doch wieder
Early Access,
Earliest Access,
Pre-Early Access und was?
Das hast du nicht gesehen.
eine woche früher gut ich kann es eine woche früher spielen weil ich werde mich
kaufen ich werde das mit einem ea player aber mal ausprobieren
vielleicht bin ich auch zu faul und kaufs mit russland
A prepurchasen würde ich nicht.
Nicht nach Battlefield 2042.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass Battlefield 3
29 Maps hat?
29!
Wenn ich es jetzt richtig im Kopf hab.
Das kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen in der heutigen Zeit, oder?
Dass ein Game wirklich voller Content ist.
Ne, ne.
Mit allen vier DLCs natürlich.
Aber guck mal, in welcher Geschwindigkeit die DLCs rausgehauen haben.
Und in 2042 brauchen sie irgendwie für eine Map ein halbes Jahr.
ich habe den eindruck dass gerade bei den ganzen super krassen triple a spielen dass
da keiner mehr sitzt der richtig bock auf hat dieses game zu machen sondern dass das alles
immer so dienst nach vorschrift ist irgendwie oder oder eben das trifft vielleicht nicht auf
den einzelnen programmierer zu die leute die halt die marschrichtung für so ein game vorgeben nicht
Nein, habe ich nicht gespielt, will ich aber spielen.
RF Programmer.
Das soll nämlich ganz gut sein, habe ich gelesen.
Für RPG-Fans.
Guck mal.
wie viele gute Maps es in Battlefield 3
gab für Rush. Die haben quasi
ohne Mühe, ohne
so, als wäre es der easiest Mode
für die, gute
Rush-Maps rausgehauen. Bam, nächster
DLC, gute Rush-Maps. Bam, nächster
DLC, gute Rush-Maps. Bam, nächster DLC.
Sind nicht alle Maps in Rush.
Kaka Island ist sucked beispielsweise
in Rush oder
die Armored-Kill-DLC-Maps
fand ich jetzt nicht so geil.
Aber zum größten Teil hast du bestimmt
15 gute Rush-Maps.
mal auf
ok all boards mountain keine gute russland gefällt mir nicht armut schielt und welche
waren das noch mal auch keine gute raschmann kann egal was hat die palace bin mir nicht sicher ob
ich das nicht durcheinander bringen im kopf glaube ich taucht ganz gut den bäumen fest gute russien
noch scharke russisch so naja ist aber kann man definitiv spielen banner deshalb mittelmäßig
Caspian Border ist eine gute Rush Map,
Demmerman Peak ist eine super Rush Map,
Death Valley war ganz okay Rush Map,
Donnie Afford, das kann ich mir nicht dran erinnern,
Epicenter ist eine richtig gute,
richtig gute Map,
Grand Bazaar, super Rush Map,
Grifo Formal, auch eine gute Rush Map,
Carg Island, naja,
Dingsbums hier, Railroad, auch eine gute Rush Map,
das kann sein, dass ich es durcheinander bringe,
aber ich glaube auch eine gute Rush Map,
das habe ich oben verwechselt,
die ist ganz gut,
auch in Rush,
Wake Island Rush ist so, naja
Siebertower ist keine Rush Map
Siebertower ist nur
Close Quarters
Terran Highway, super Rush Map
Talamark, super Rush Map, Sharky, gute Rush Map
Sign Crossing, Poggers Rush Map
Scrap Metal ist Close Quarters
Samarland Pipeline geht so
als Rush, Operation Riverside
ist eine gute Rush Map, Metro ist eine gute
Rush Map, Firestorm ist
mir persönlich gefällt die nicht so gut
Keine Ahnung, glaube auch noch
close quarters map kann ich mich daran erinnern ja also die haben wirklich da
am laufenden band bäume bäume gute raps rauskommt es kommt ob das überhaupt
stimmt in 29 ich glaube das sind nämlich viel weniger hier oder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 1 22 23 24 25 28 29 stehen 29
und zwar habe ich richtig erzählt
das ist kein begann vorstellen überlegt einmal die haben alle paar
monate vier neue maps rausgehauen haben alle was getaucht heute brauchen ein
halbes jahr für eine map die lieber gut ist wie sind wir so weit gekommen
Max hast du das Barcode Video gesehen? Das Barcode Video? Ne das Barcode Video habe ich nicht gekonnt.
Wir wussten es damals gar nicht zu schätzen richtig. Manchmal weiß man nur was man hatte wenn man es nicht mehr hat.
was sagst du den neuen iphones ich habe mir noch nicht angeguckt weil so das teuer ist
ja die haben ein bisschen das problem dass keiner mehr sich mit frostbite auskennt
aber das muss doch mit der manpower davon den griff zu kriegen sein
Was?
Die Barkhautverschwörung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Braucht das?
Ich glaub nicht.
Check Alu.
Ja?
Okay.
Aber jetzt können wir das nicht mehr gucken, weil ich muss jetzt gleich auf...
Die sind selbst schuld.
Die haben das nicht richtig beworben.
Also ja, selbst schuld.
Die haben sich schon sehr viel Mühe gegeben.
Die haben das nicht richtig beworben.
Und die hatten lange Zeit ein Memory-Leak drin,
was das alles wieder gecrasht hat.
Da sind die eh schon wenigen Spiele abgehauen.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen,
sollten die wirklich mal die offiziellen
Battlefield-3-Server dicht machen,
was die Leute dann über Venice
weiterspielen werden.
Was geht hier?
Gerade nichts mehr. Ich bin fertig mit dem Stream.
Viertelstunde bin ich off.
Näh.
Ist es nicht.
man kann es jetzt spielen das aber auch alles die grundprobleme sind ja immer noch da
beispielsweise die ganze specialist geschichte und dass die maps übelst viel zu clean und
und lieblos ausschauen.
Kann nicht sein.
Bist nicht subscribed.
Die Maps sind überarbeitet.
Ja, aber die haben ein paar Kisten überall hingestellt.
Ich weiß.
Die haben überall Kisten hingestellt.
Aber das macht die Maps nicht detaillierter.
und sind immer noch viel zu clean aus.
Wird auch noch gelegentlich
Kreiselgrind durchgeführt. Ja, mir ging es ja die letzten
Wochen und Monate nicht so gut.
Wenig Kreiselgrind.
Kannst du.
Es gibt ein Battlefield
Bad Company
Projekt, wie ist das Projekt?
Rome, glaube ich. Da kannst du
Bad Company 2 noch spielen.
Hast du was verpasst? Der Recap ist,
es geht einfach, ohne
dass man was machen muss.
Wie oft streamst du so agile?
Ich weiß nicht, wir müssen erstmal, würde ich sagen,
Daily Scrum machen,
um das zu entscheiden stand up nächstes sprint nächster sprint muss geplant werden
mikro sprints machen wir
du bist quasi schon wieder am sprint planen noch bevor der alte sprint fertig ist eine
minute arbeit eine minute sprintplan
Wenn wir noch ein Katzen Video schauen, ja
können wir aber ein gutes
hast du eins nach dem vorschlag
auf discord moment kannst du hier posten ich glaube ich habe hier
gerade ich bin ich bin nicht eingeloggt auf dem 2 rechner
Ich habe heute wieder eine getroffen
auf dem Weg draußen.
Habe ich bestimmt
da vielleicht nicht 10 Minuten,
aber an die 10 Minuten
Katze-Bespaßung
gemacht beim Spazierengehen.
Ich kenne die meisten ja schon
in dieser,
auf dieser Runde.
ein erster eindruck iphone 17 er wenn es gibt jetzt ein iphone ist das neu ich bin
eingeloggt auf das gott kann gar nicht gucken
guck wenn ich ausgeloggt bin hier ist neue
ich glaube die waren einfach noch nicht zu teuer oder
wir haben nur 1600 euro gekostet da geht noch was
ich habe auch nicht vor mir neues iphone zu holen eins tut ich hole mir neues was
gehabt er jetzt mehr gibt fertig macht jetzt keinen großen akt kauf mir doch
nicht jedes jahr für nach für für laufend geld neues iphone
mein usb 2 0 wirklich ich dachte die haben jetzt usb anschluss und unterstützen
dementsprechend. Also ich weiß, dass USB-C und
Übertragung, dass es nichts miteinander zu tun hat, ja.
Aber ich dachte mir, wenn man schon einen USB-Anschluss hat,
dann
einen USB-C-Anschluss hat, dann kann man auch ein bisschen
was Neueres unterstützen, so.
Es ist ja nicht mehr
USB-3, es ist USB-4
Gen 3
mal 1 oder sowas.
Dann bist du kein Konsumopfer.
Doch, aber ich kaufe halt nicht nur iPhones.
Nur beim Pro ist es 3.
Krass.
Genau, das meine ich.